Traductor: Carmen de Miguel-Murado
Revisor: Sabrina Mattheus
Ver la luz que entra por la ventana.
No llorar al pensar en el nuevo día.
Decidir levantarte.
Sentarte en la cama.
Poner un pie en el suelo.
Poner el otro.
Dar el primer paso del día.
Pensar en todos los pasos que
vas a tener que dar a lo largo del día.
No llorar.
Ducharte.
Lavarte el pelo.
Que te importe lavarte el pelo.
Lavarte los dientes.
Mirarte en el espejo,
reconocerte.
Ponerte zapatos.
Ponerte calcetines.
Cambiarte los calcetines después
de 15 días de usar los mismos.
Que te importe cambiarte de calcetines.
Hacer la compra.
Acordarte de hacer la compra.
Que te importe lo que compres.
Que te importe lo que comes.
Ir en metro.
Ver el cielo azul.
No llorar cuando tus hijas te preguntan:
"Mamá, ¿qué te pasa? ¿por qué lloras?
Pensar, pensar, pensar.
Dejar de pensar que eres una inútil,
que no vales para nada,
que ojalá te mueras.
Cuando tienes una depresión
todas las cosas que te salían solas,
que dabas por supuestas,
se convierten en algo espeluznante,
imposible de hacer.
La primera vez que dije:
"tengo una depresión"
me sentí ridícula, me dio vergüenza,
porque era como reconocer en alto
que había fallado, que era una débil,
que no sabía vivir,
que no tenía fuerza de voluntad.
Pero era ese pelín de fuerza
de voluntad que me quedaba,
el que me permitía decir:
"tengo una depresión".
¿Cuántos de los que estamos
en esta sala, probablemente todos,
hemos dicho en el último día,
en la última semana,
en el último mes y seguro
que en el último año:
"Qué depresión, qué deprimente,
qué depresivo, qué depresión tengo",
cuando lo que nos pasaba era que
habíamos discutido con nuestro jefe,
nos había dejado nuestra pareja,
nos habíamos divorciado,
nuestros hijos nos habían dado un disgusto
había un atasco descomunal
o llovía en nuestra semana de vacaciones?
Todos.
Decimos tantas y tantas veces
esas palabras
que las hemos frivolizado,
las hemos vaciado de contenido,
y cuando quieres usarlas para
contarle al mundo que estás destruido
y que te quieres morir,
te parecen pequeñas, te parecen absurdas,
te parece que no sirven.
Y es que no sirven,
porque tú no quieres decir:
"tengo una depresión" o "estoy deprimido",
tú lo que quieres decir es:
"soy una depresión".
Durante los meses y los años
que dura tu depresión
todo lo que antes te hacía feliz,
todo lo que antes te hacía ser tú,
tu familia, tu pareja, tus amigos,
tu trabajo, tus aficiones, tus hobbies,
todo se vuelve indiferente,
te importa una mierda.
Pero es que a veces hasta se convierte
en algo hostil, en algo terrible.
Creemos que sabemos
lo que es una depresión.
Creemos que para tener una depresión
hay que ser un determinado tipo de persona
alguien solitario, con pocos amigos,
que tenga problemas de cualquier tipo,
que no se relacione con su familia,
o creemos que para tener una depresión
te ha tenido que pasar algo en la vida,
algo que nos pasa a todos,
y tú, como no has sabido resolverlo,
tienes una depresión.
Por eso, cuando alguien famoso,
como Bruce Springsteen o como Iniesta,
confiesa públicamente que tiene
una depresión, ¿qué decimos?
"Pero ¿cómo vas a tener tú una depresión?"
Porque si tienes éxito, si tienes
pareja, si tienes dinero,
si no tienes preocupaciones económicas,
ni de salud ni nada,
tú no puedes tener una depresión.
Además, tampoco sabemos
cómo duele una depresión.
De hecho, ni siquiera sabemos
que una depresión duele.
Nos creemos que tener una depresión es
estar muy triste por un desengaño amoroso
o estar llevando un luto terrible
por la muerte de un ser querido,
o tener preocupaciones económicas,
preocupaciones materiales,
o tener una época en la que no te apetece
hacer nada y estás desganado,
y todo eso, multiplicado por un millón,
estar triste, estar aburrido,
estar enfadado, tener el corazón roto
o estar atravesando un luto terrible,
todo eso, multiplicado por un millón,
no se parece a lo que es
tener una depresión.
Sufrir una depresión es
no saber quién eres,
no reconocerte en el cuerpo,
sin fuerzas y sin voluntad,
que cada mañana llora porque
no se puede enfrentar al nuevo día,
porque cree que no va a llegar al final
de ese día, que no va a ser capaz.
Sufrir una depresión es estar
ahogándote y querer ahogarte,
es querer pedir ayuda y al mismo tiempo
querer morirte todo el tiempo.
Sufrir una depresión es ver
a tu familia, a tu pareja, a tus hijos,
y no poder quererlos,
y que te dé igual no poder quererlos.
Sufrir una depresión es tener más miedo
del que has tenido en toda tu vida,
más miedo del que creías
que se podía tener.
¿Y qué te da miedo?
Te da miedo vivir.
La depresión es una sucesión
de días y días iguales.
Son días llenos de soledad, de angustia,
de ansiedad, de miedo,
de una tristeza más grande que tu vida,
y de pánico.
Estás en medio de tus días iguales
y no sabes cómo has llegado allí.
No eres capaz de pensar
en qué persona eras antes.
No sabes quién eras antes.
Y además llega un momento
en que pierdes la esperanza
de que esos días iguales vayan a terminar
y te quieres morir.
Y los demás no lo ven.
La depresión molaría muchísimo más
y sería una enfermedad
muchísimo mejor entendida,
y a los enfermos nos daría
menos vergüenza contarlo,
si en vez de ser algo que te va
carcomiendo por dentro,
hasta que te destruye por completo
sin que los demás lo vean,
fuera algo espectacular,
y te levantaras un día
con el pelo naranja,
la piel azul, y las uñas
llegándote al suelo.
Porque entonces la gente diría:
"¡Pobrecilla, tiene una depresión!"
Pero no es así,
y como no la vemos y como todas las ideas
que tenemos sobre la depresión
vienen dadas de no sabemos
muy bien qué, y son equivocadas,
cuando nos enfrentamos
a que alguien, un conocido,
nos dice que tiene una depresión,
lo hacemos todo mal.
Lo primero que hacemos es juzgarlo.
La misma expresión: "Ana ha entrado
en depresión" "Ana ha caído en depresión"
implica voluntariedad
por parte del enfermo.
Has caído en depresión porque
te ha pasado algo en la vida,
lo que sea, que nos pasa a todos,
te has caído y en vez de levantarte,
como hacemos todos, te has caído ahí.
estás ahí porque quieres,
o has entrado porque tienes
determinado carácter
y te ha dado por reconcentrarte ahí.
Lo segundo que hacemos es desplegar
un millón de consejos bienintencionados,
y os aseguro que a mí me los dieron todos,
que son superdolorosos para el enfermo.
Le decimos: "¡Anímate, esto son unos días,
esto nos ha pasado a todos!",
"lo que tienes que hacer es dejar de
reconcomerte, es que te regodeas en ello".
Y luego vienen los de: "¿Has probado a...?
"hacer más ejercicio", "madrugar",
"hacer yoga", "meditación".
"no comas carne", "come más carne",
"no comas gluten", "come más gluten".
Y tú dices: "No".
Y luego lo siguiente es juzgarte.
Entonces tú dices, con un mínimo
de fuerza de voluntad que te queda,
desde lo más hondo de tu desesperación:
"Tengo una depresión".
Y te dicen:
"Pero cómo vas a tener tú una depresión".
Con lo cual el enfermo se encuentra
con que, si está ahí, es porque quiere,
si no sale, es porque no quiere,
y además, ni siquiera tiene
el derecho de estar enfermo.
No me gusta decir que aprendí
algo de mi depresión,
porque no quiero convertirla en algo
bueno, en algo que mereciera la pena.
Yo no soy mejor persona ahora
de la que era antes de tener la depresión,
ni veo el mundo de luz y de color,
ni os veo a todos mejores.
No quiero convertir mi depresión
en eso que está tan de moda,
que es una experiencia.
Ojalá no la hubiera experimentado.
Ojalá no me hubiera pasado
quince meses sin poder trabajar,
más de seis meses, más de ocho, yendo a
conducir aullando de dolor y de ansiedad,
gritando en el coche.
Ojalá no hubiera pensado:
"Que alguien se lleve a mis hijas,
porque yo no puedo estar con ellas".
No aprendí nada de mi depresión,
de lo que he aprendido es de contarlo,
de decirle a todo el mundo:
Sí, yo tuve una depresión.
Sí, yo me pasaba las tardes en el sofá
pensando que si esto seguía,
tendría que pensar en
alguna manera de morirme.
Y he aprendido, contándoselo a la gente,
que no sabemos lo que es esa depresión,
y que por eso actuamos mal.
Porque lo primero que deberíamos
saber todos como sociedad
es que tener una depresión no se elige.
Nadie elige desconectarse de su familia,
de sus amigos, de su vida,
de lo que le hacía ser él.
Nadie elige sentirse tan solo que le dé
miedo salir de la cama por las mañanas.
No se elige tener una depresión.
Además, tenemos que aprender
que una depresión es una enfermedad
que podemos tener todos.
No hay un determinado tipo de persona
susceptible de tener una enfermedad.
Nos puede pasar a todos.
Me pasó a mí y ahora sé que puede
volver a pasarme y me da miedo.
Y además tenemos que saber
que cuando alguien nos dice:
"Tengo una depresión"
no lleva tres días, ni tres semanas,
ni tres meses,
lleva muchísimo tiempo,
y no quiere que le digas: "Anímate".
Lo que necesita es tiempo y
espacio para estar enfermo.
Lo que necesita es ir al médico
y tomar antidepresivos,
aunque nadie quiere tomar antidepresivos.
Necesita ir a terapia y hacer terapia,
aunque nadie quiere hacer terapia.
Y necesita sobre todo el tiempo
y el espacio para estar enfermo.
La mayoría de las depresiones,
el 70 %, se curan,
pero es un tiempo larguísimo,
mucho más del que los enfermos
y su familia querrían,
porque además, el médico no te puede decir
"Te quedan cuatro meses, te quedan seis,
te quedan ocho".
Ojalá te lo pudiera decir,
porque ponerle un horizonte
temporal al sufrimiento
lo hace menor, lo encajona,
lo hace llevadero,
pero no te lo van a decir.
Y por eso necesitas convertirte
en paciente y tener paciencia.
Que un familiar tuyo o que un amigo tuyo
tenga una depresión, da mucho miedo,
porque cuando de verdad ves
lo destruido que está, aterroriza.
Y por eso tendemos a decirle: ¡anímate!
Exigimos que tire de unas fuerzas
que de verdad no tiene,
porque no queremos verlo,
y eso es lo que no tenemos que hacer.
Ojalá todos los enfermos de depresión
tuvieran a alguien como mi hermana,
que la noche antes
de romperme por completo,
en septiembre de 2014,
mientras yo lloraba abrazada
al volante de mi coche,
temblando de frío porque
no podía más, me dijo:
"Ana, no sabemos qué te pasa,
pero estamos asustadísimos,
porque te estamos viendo sufrir tanto
que no sabemos qué hacer,
pero vamos a buscar ayuda
y vamos a acompañarte".
Los enfermos de depresión
necesitamos que nos acompañéis,
aunque sea largo y dé mucho miedo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)